why from E I be Southern Command
headquarters the most listened to talk
radio host in the history of the medium
radio talk show legend Rush Limbaugh hey
Rush how are you I am fabulous it's
great to be with you tonight you know
for those that never got you with half
my brain tied behind my back in a lot of
ways you're like Trump you say these
things and people bubble and fizz like
alka-seltzer they have no sense of you
were I'm not sure if I got that I got
through we get stuck on the thing so you
say controversial things also and you're
joking when you say half my brain tied
behind my back
well no actually I do I split my skull
open and I take half of it behind my
back it's like when I say Talent on the
loan from God I mean these people he's
he's calling himself believe you know
Shawn I've been listening to your whole
show these the people that we're talking
about tonight don't have a sense of
humor to them life is a war every day of
their lives is a battle we are the enemy
their effort is to eliminate us al Qaeda
is not their enemy and Isis is not their
enemy and socialism is not their enemy
coming that we are conservative and
Republican America in their view are the
obstacles in their way to their desire
to create this totalitarian state that
they think is good at being a utopia and
I was listening to to you and Don jr.
talking about this should never ever
happen again
I have to I have to clarify it is not
over it is still happening the Democrat
Party and the media and all of these
people from the Obama administration who
ran this scandal are still running it
the objective remains to get Donald
Trump out of office either by driving
his numbers down or impeaching him or
defeating him in 2020 today the New York
Times has this story that the Muller
report is 300 pages and the
bar summary is four pages therefore bar
is lying Pelosi literally said that we
cannot trust the Attorney General so
what we're being led to believe by these
people remember they have to feed their
beast with this fake news constantly
they have created a monster that
believes and absorbs and needs fake news
like vampires need your blood and these
people are believing now that there is
evidence of collusion in the Muller
report and that bar is not telling the
truth
and the New York Times is leading this
effort the rest of the drive-by media is
gonna pick it up because it prolongs the
narrative that Trump is unworthy that
Trump cheated that we need to redo the
election results 2016 so we're being led
to believe that this report does contain
evidence of collusion bars lying about
it now if this is so silly
if it contains evidence of collusion
then where is Muller on television all
nights and wait a minute wait a minute
that's not what my report says my report
has plenty of evidence of collusion I
have all these anti Hillary people on my
staff we found all kinds of evidence and
Maher is like why is it mother doing
that if Barr is lying about what's in
the report so it is an on-going effort
to continue to attack and impune the
integrity and the and the the decency
and and the qualifications of Donald
Trump to be President of the United
States it's not going to stop the media
I mean look look at this if I told this
story on the radio today if I had lied
to my audience for two years that I knew
Hillary Clinton was being investigated
I had sources and that she was going
down and she was gonna be locked up you
can count on me you can believe me I'm
hearing it from people that I trust it
is gonna happen two years every day on
my program 15 hours a week i pummel
people with this and then it turns out
to be not true I'm finished I can't face
my audience again I've lied to them they
wouldn't want anything to do with me I
would try to apologize but I wouldn't
get away with it because I would have
exploited them I would have used them I
would have
with them I would have manipulated I
would have lied to this exact thing has
happened from MSNBC to CNN to the New
York Times to the Washington Post
they're lying to everybody and their
audiences don't seem to care just give
us more fake news they want it they
can't accept that it's not true they
can't accept that Donald Trump is not a
traitor they're not happy to learn that
their president is not a foreign agent
they're unhappy we're dealing with
deranged people who are not rational we
can't we can't deal with them rationally
karl rove today said mr. president you
need to move on you don't need to do an
investigation you don't need to find out
what happened swing voters don't care
one thing that i heard that you guys
were discussing and i completely agree
with we have got to get to the bottom of
this we've got to have people named they
have to be held accountable if jail time
is called for they need to go to jail
they knowingly lied to the american
people the media were willingly
complicit in this they were not fooled
they wanted it all to be true they ran a
scam they ran an effort to try to get
Donald Trump thrown out of office
normally they're able to get rid of
Republican presidents whatever they want
to but they failed with Trump so now
they're doing a new tack the Muller
report must contain some evidence boy
it's 300 pages they're not going to give
this up and this is why there needs to
be I don't know if it's a special
counsel I don't know if it's literally
charging people but we need to get to
the bottom of this and find out just how
high up the Obama totem pole this goes
and I think it goes all the way up to
Obama I don't know how he didn't know
about this Brennan clapper all of these
people in his regime leadership in the
FBI it's not enough to call it the worst
scandal in the world they almost got
away with this Sean and the fact that we
say it could never be allowed to happen
again it's still happening they haven't
changed their tax oh ever the objective
remains get rid of Trump defeat us
however they can you know I'm listening
very very closely to what you're saying
that was with half my brain tied behind
my
by the way can you see me put it yeah
towel are long from God praises God if
you really think about it does that not
to take it you know
I've listened to you you syndicated the
last year of Ronald Reagan you've been a
leader of the conservative movement what
you are saying is scary that this is an
attempted coup that it is totally scary
I don't think the American people
understand this was not ladies and
gentlemen I don't doubt me here it was
not an investigation there was never any
evidence of collusion Robert Muller took
this gig and opened his investigation
without evidence there was no evidence
he wasn't even given a specific crime to
pursue it was open it was go find a
crime because there weren't any crimes
that had been committed but what we just
went through was not an investigation
Robert Muller has known for a minimum
folks of 18 months that there was no
collusion why did he not shut it down 18
why did he take the gig he took the job
knowing there was no collusion the only
collusion we've been seeing it and
infinitum is Hillary Clinton with the
Russians and steel creating this dossier
and they try to pass this off as
legitimate Intel you need some a Brennan
or layer he met with the House Democrats
yesterday this isn't over as far as
they're concerned and and Brennan is the
guy who passed the dossier to Harry Reid
everybody thinks that was McCain and
McCain played a role in this but this
was not an investigation this was a coup
this was an attempt to find the crime
and the fact that they couldn't with all
of this money and 19 people on his
investigative team at least the lawyers
who were from the anti-trump camp they
donors to Hillary Clinton and they
couldn't find it it's Sean and ladies
and gentlemen you have to know that this
the passage in the Muller report where
it says numerous end treaties were made
by Russians to the Trump campaign but
the Trump campaign
that's not what happened what happened
is the FBI attempted to plant their own
informers in the Trump campaign one of
them name's Stephon helper a Cambridge
professor mi6 UK they tried to get him
hired in the foreign policy advisory
role here during the campaign and
fortunately whoever interviewed him
didn't hire him if he had been hired and
they tried to get to other people if
they had been hired guess what they
would have done they would have started
communicating with Russian agents they
know and then there would have been the
collusion that the FBI was trying to
create there wasn't any this is worse
than anybody is being led to believe it
is because it's being called an
investigation and Trump passed the test
they didn't find anything they're not
finished
they aren't through trying to get rid of
Donald Trump they're not through trying
to overturn the election results of 2016
they're never going to finish trying to
get rid of even if he's elected in 2020
they're setting up the impeachment now
with all of this stuff it's never that's
why these people need to be politically
defeated and pounded into the ground to
the point of irrelevance and the way to
do it is to educate as many Americans as
possible to what happened and you can't
do that by moving on and say okay well
we escape this one gang let's move on to
the next agenda item here which better
be immigration by the way it is it is
not finished and it wasn't an
investigation there was no evidence ever
of collusion it should never have begun
Rosenstein should have never appointed
anybody the FISA warrants the spy of the
Trump campaign were illegal the judges
there were either complicit in this or
they were lied to and now don't care
we've got a two-tier justice system the
very foundations of this country have
been attacked and assaulted and the
people who know it in the mainstream
media are complicit in it instead of
trying to blow it up and explain it to
the American people we're at a very very
dangerous point in the history of our
nation and there's just one
i standing up against all of this and
that's trump there's not another
republican that i know of maybe you do
Sean there's not another Republican that
could have withstood what Trump's put up
with for one week they would have been
suing for peace they would have been
giving up they would have acknowledged
all this and resigned it is it is a
stroke of luck here that we've had Trump
to put up with this but the fact that it
was attempted by unelected the
counterintelligence apparatus of this
country CIA dia NSA was turned against
one man and his family and by extension
his supporters in his administration
because he had the audacity to win and
defeat Hillary Clinton and these
unelected people these arrogant elite
effete snobs in the so-called deep state
administrative state simply couldn't
abide it and have not stopped
McCabe's still not selling his book on
the basis that there's collusion and we
see pencil-neck out there claiming that
they're still collusion and we gots whoa
well these guys in ought to prove to
everybody that it is an ongoing
political project to get rid of Trump
they don't care about whether or not the
Russians actually spied or actually
affected the election because they know
it didn't happen and if if somebody was
given the order to rig a presidential
election I don't even think it's
possible and Obama even said so so this
whole premise is ridiculous it's it's
not legitimate and yet everybody's
dealing with this is those serious
investigation why do we dodged the
bullet Trump related it was it's not an
investigation this was an attempt to
throw him out of office just because he
won and they didn't like it it's no more
complicated Matt that is an
extraordinary monologue you know rush
there's a few teleprompter here Sean no
tell no you did not that's all
extemporaneous you know there are few of
us here at Fox
primetime Laura Tucker Fox and Friends
there's you leading and talk radio I'm
on talk radio mark and talk radio I've
had an ensemble cast on this show that
have dug deep the 99.9% of media
drive-bys bought it sold it hook line
and sinker and as they always do get it
wrong that's never going to change isn't
by anything they didn't buy anything
they were in on it they don't feel any
remorse they're unhappy they failed they
don't they don't care they lied to their
audiences they're not worried if their
audiences are going to reject them
they're not worried if their audiences
now don't trust them or believe them
they were in on it they were complicit
they considered themselves to be part of
this elite gang inside the beltway that
runs the town and and they were in on it
and so all it is now is that they have
failed you know I saw something where
MSNBC prime time had a sudden
inexplicable 20% loss in audience one
night this week now what does that tell
you you're a broadcast professional I'm
a naturally talented highly trained
specialist let me taste him when she
loses Rachel Maddow or C in it when they
lose 20 percent of their audience just
because this thing bombed out it it
tells me that their audience is there
not because of those people but because
of the faint news and when the fake news
bombs out when when all these
expectations that Trump is going to jail
Trump is going down well he's not it
didn't happen they failed and so MSNBC
cannot cannot serve their expectations
anymore and their hosts are not enough
to hold the audience it's it's nothing
other than a testament to the fact that
they create an audience that wants to
believe a bunch of Lies wants to believe
the worst about their country because
they get up every day doing that already
and now what are they going to do that's
why these people have to come up with
the new hook
the mullah report is 300 pages bar
summary is for there's got to be
collusion and now they're trying to get
my work back up lying to them again
continually lying to a misrepresenting
the truth manipulating these P it's no
wonder we can't come together Sean
whoever it is that watches the drive-by
media and primetime cable on the left
there's no way we can ever happening in
common with them they're being told
they're being instructed to literally
hate this country because it's unjust
it's unfair it was founded it morally or
something
this is a dire circumstance when facts
and truth don't even have a chance with
a certain segment of the population when
they have been trained and conditioned
to want to believe the worst and what
that you would think that they would be
happy that the president didn't collude
that the Russians didn't determine the
outcome of the election but now look
what they've even done that that every
election going forward is tainted the
Russians every time the Democrats lose
it's gonna be some external factor it
can't be that they lost because they
were rejected no it's gonna be the
Russians or some other foreign agent got
in there and cheated and stole it from
whoever their next nominee is it is a
that's why there shouldn't be any
attempt across the aisle make common
ground we don't have any common ground
with them they need to be pummeled into
the political dirt and become
acknowledged as the minority they are
and I'm dead serious about this dead
serious about it it's it's weird a
crisis in this country because the media
has given up even the pretense of
objectivity they are now leftist
activists pushing an agenda and this one
failed so it's on to the next one as I
listened to you really closely this is
ongoing but there's another factor look
to 2020 new green deal what do you see
on the horizon politically okay look
here it it what is the selling point of
the green new deal that we've got 12
year
to live that 5% of the nation of the
world's population because of the United
States to blame right it's the United
States has to engage in all the fixes
the United States has to do all the
reparations United States has to fix it
because we are destroying the climate 5%
of the world's population and we've only
got 12 years let me say if we've only
got 12 years then we better just throw
everything out the window and start
doing everything we want to do every day
because we're going to be dandy in 12
years if we don't in that they're stupid
it's absurd the idea that anybody could
believe this intellectually if they
actually take a moment by the way how
many I remember in 1988 I'm watching
this week needs David Brinkley and
they've got some guy on there Allen top
and we've only got 20 years the save the
world can you prove this is happen well
no but we can't take the chance that it
isn't so we need to implement policies
immediately then in ted danson came
along in 1988 so we get 10 years if we
don't fix the oceans we're gonna die
this is something that gets recycled we
don't even have the power to impact the
climate we can't change it for better or
worse but it is constantly changing all
we can do is adapt to it we're the best
in the world at that green new deal they
can't even support it in the Senate when
it comes up for a vote and it's another
lie and it's another example of how
they're manipulating and misrepresenting
their unfortunately sick face the thick
base wants to hear this they they want
to hear that we're gonna die they want
to hear the apocalypse is coming they
want to hear that life is nothing but
eternal suffering they want somebody to
pay the price for it if it's the rich if
it's billionaires of its corporations if
it's Republicans or whoever else so
these people are happy they are happy to
lie to their own voters and tell them
life ends in twelve years unless we do
what retrofit every building stopped
cows from farting stop eating be it it
is it's insane
right and you can go through there yes I
know I've got diarrhea Donna Jean I'm
sorry listen I really have one more
question I don't I don't get you in the
chicken can you stay I got off charged
confess Kotori rates they're gonna kill
me for not breaking and you stay for one
more question
yeah I'm just light a cigar here while
you're doing that everything about all
right as we continue our exclusive rush
limbaugh rush this may go down as your
greatest rant ever but the most
important the prison no no I'm serious
extraordinary happens when you have a
lot of no but it's what happens when you
have a lot of time so I appreciate that
Sean you're uh you're very very generous
listen this is really important we're
gonna ask you you say we must defeat
them 2020s around the corner how well
obviously
defeating him requires the president
being re-elected and I'm gonna tell you
in my estimation the one thing that he
needs to zero in on is immigration I
know he wants he wants the Republican
Party to become known as the party of
health care because that you know that's
a tangible thing that really matters to
every human being in this country but
I'm telling you he was elected on
immigration and stopping it Sean we we
suspended immigration in the United
States from 1920 I think one through
1965 in order to assimilate all those
who had come into the country legally
from the late 18-hundreds through 1920
Ellis Island all that we had to
assimilate them they had to become
Americans had to join American society
American culture that isn't happening we
have a political party opening the
border for illegal immigrants that come
what happened to the room of law I think
the president should shut the border if
he shuts the border and builds the wall
there is nobody Shawn that can beat him
in 2020 it remains the issue for the
vast majority of freedom-loving
Constitution loving American loving
citizens if it doesn't happen the
country that we know and love
always gonna be in America but it's not
gonna be comic-con it's not going to
remain a constitutional republic as
founded if we don't get ahead it's
nothing about these people that makes
them bad it's the rule of law once once
you allow people to break the law once
you signal lawlessness is okay then
where does it stop these people are not
being conditioned to assimilate the
Democrats don't want them to assimilate
the Democrats want to keep them poor
want to keep them dependent so they will
always vote Democrats the Democrats are
not compassionate people the Democrats
need a permanent underclass they want
these people to come in here remain poor
Ramin remain in need if they're going to
be here let's turn them into productive
people that can help this country grow
but right now we've got to stop the flow
and if Trump does that Shawn with a wall
or shutting the border for a little
while to make sure we get a handle on
those or in the country now nobody can
beat him let me go to the other issue
and that is the economy foreign policy
you know here's the bigger question
where is the backbone of other
Republicans I'm not a Republican right
I'm not registered Republican I'm a
conservative because I think they're
weak where was their backbone well we we
talk this about this a lot every time we
get together and the Republicans for the
first nine months of Trump's first year
thought they believe this indle crap and
they thought Trump was gone so they
wouldn't get behind the agenda half of
who didn't want him to win look at all
the Republicans that resigned ostensibly
because they were losing their committee
chairmanships but we wouldn't have
suffered this massive main the midterm
loss if so many hadn't resigned the
Republican Party is not unified American
conservatism is not unified and so right
now Donald Trump remains the unifying
figure or at least the blunt-force
figure that can't look everybody wants
to be in the in the bright lights of
winning even these Republicans are
talking about they'll be
had to show up when the Fighting's over
and shake hands and put their hands in
the air in the bright lights and act
like they played a role in it but maybe
so but but but waiting along waiting
around for them to get on board is I
don't think we have the luxury to do
that we have to bring them on board like
we have to bring the swing voters to our
side not go defensive and try not to
offend anybody and hope we show them
we're nice people if we haven't proven
that we're nice people after all of
these years it's a lost cause we have to
engage in issues that matter most of the
American people are going to improve
their lives gonna make them feel trust
and and hopeful about their country and
their future there are gobs of people
that want to feel this way there are
gobs of people out there that want to be
proud of this country and I just tap
into it and make it happen I see that
yep yep yep there I go again no no thank
you
listen thank you this is perhaps an epic
monologue that will be looked at for
years we can't thank you enough for us
thank you very much